good evening everyone
looks like everyone's made it over this
is
wonderful it's my
honor and privilege to introduce this
evening speaker
victor davis hanson
is a farmer
he is a farmer on the family farm that
has been farmed
for five generations
being a farmer makes one practical
wise and aware of the world around them
he's not just aware of the world around
him however he has studied the classical
world up to the present world
he earned a phd at stanford university
in classics and then went on to found a
very successful classics program at cal
state fresno
after leaving cal state fresno he went
back to his alma mater stanford where he
joined the hoover institution
and is the martin and ellie anderson
senior fellow in residence at the hoover
institution
but he's also a faculty member at
hillsdale college where he comes every
year to teach
[Applause]
he's been coming here since roughly
1998.
he is the wayne and marcia buskie
distinguished fellow in history here in
hillsdale
he is an award-winning scholar
he has been awarded the national
humanities medal the bradley prize the
edmond burke award the william buckley
prize the claremont institute's
statesmanship award and others
he has been an advisor to statesman
he has been a teacher of young people
he's a generous and kind
person and he's here to talk to us
tonight
about a pressing issue
the dying citizen which is the title of
his new book
this new book released by basic books
will be published on october 5th you can
already pre-order it on amazon
happily for some and not so for others
we were able to secure 200
pre-publication copies
that dr hansen has signed and they will
be available for purchase after this
evening's event out in the lobby
if you're not at the front of the queue
no worries he has also signed
just as many book plates that can go
inside a book
and you are free to order a copy we have
order forms and you can order a copy and
receive that book with a signed book
plate within it as well if this is
something you're interested in this will
take place out those doors after dr
hansen's lecture
when he finishes his speech however
there will be some time for q a
and i would ask that if you have a
question you please wait until the
microphone re reaches you
uh it's important for two reasons you
want dr hansen to be able to hear the
question but you also want the folks who
are still over in the serial center to
be able to hear your question as well
so those are our marching orders for
this evening but rather than hearing me
give marching orders i'd rather hear you
speak to a wonderful man and great
teacher victor hansen please join me in
welcoming
thank you mark i enjoy every year coming
here my wife says uh she doesn't call it
hillsdale she said
you're on your way to see mark kalkhoff
and tom connor and al philip we three of
us have been hanging around for 18 years
so it's i feel like it's home
i speak a lot of universities and
they're usually hostile places so when
i'm you this is a very nice introduction
i was usually introduced until recently
a guy would growl
and he'd say oh here he is a raisin
farmer from salmon california and he
teaches where jerry tarkanian is coach
at cal state fresno that was about it so
this is nice
i'd like to talk about
our contemporary
crises in the context of history
and culture and citizenship
and if you try to make sense of the
nonsense that we're seeing every day
it's very difficult you if just think of
the images on our telepho
television screens we've seen
we saw these
poor refugees flying in 100 000 of them
and i was watching this
the screen i had great empathy but i
realized that we had not screened them
and that the soldiers
who were
entrusted with
with their lives i think maybe wisely or
unwisely were asked or not i should say
mandated to get a vaccination they're
citizens but the refugees who were
arriving were not
how could such a thing be true
and after risking all of their lives
the commander
in charge of the relocation said i want
to reassure the american people
that we have the proper gender ratios in
the plane and we have culturally
sensitive food i said the united states
just suffered the most humiliating
defeat
since saigon 1975. what's going on
two million people are crossing the
border
in this fiscal year the first act is to
illegally
cross a non-existent border the second
act is to illegally reside in
a country that they don't have legal
permission to do so and the third
is to find identification that's not
legitimate to legitimize what was
illegitimate
and yet nobody raises a word
and
i i was looking at
wage gains of the middle class a person
was on television said we've had
enormous
three and a half percent wage gains but
i thought wait a minute the annual price
consumer index is rising at six percent
so
what does all this have what's going on
in the united states we say it's
wokeness it's chaos it's cova it's a
lockdown it's a recession it was trump
it's
i think it's a destruction in the idea
of a citizen us
people that had a very exceptional i
want to say very quickly that is a very
rare idea we have we assume that
since the dawn of civilization 7 000
years ago in the near east everybody was
a citizen they weren't they were
subjects they were servants they were
slaves
they were serfs it was only in greece
2500 years ago very late was there an
idea that a politics political politics
and later in rome 500 years later a
kiwis civil civilization
emerged and this was a unique idea that
the people the residents had legal
status
started out believe it or not the right
to pass on property to your errors
without interference from the government
that seems so
crass but that's what started
citizenship the right then to determine
when you and when you would not
fight and who would fight and your
national cause whether you would have a
border or not have a border and then the
idea of freedom of speech and expression
came later
but it was a very rare idea it's rare
today
of the 190 nations in the world less
than half of them are what we would call
constitutional with true citizens
so we have to remember that this idea of
a multi-racial
multi-ethnic democracy
it's it's never been tried before
india is trying it and brazil and those
are the only two large countries that
can try and they don't do very well
so the idea that we're going to have to
be perfect to be good
when all we have to do is be far better
than the alternative this is a new idea
this demand on perfection on a a very
rare
incident in the history of civilization
so
what's happening to citizens i think
it's being assaulted it being
citizenship
organically insidiously
from what i call the pre-modern level
and the first of course is
you cannot have a citizen unless you
have a middle class that goes back to
aristotle and it's a theme throughout
western thinking
to alexis dick tocqueville and why did
they say that
because they felt that the rich had
inordinate power to influence government
officials in quid pro quo fashion and
the poor would always be dependent
either on the rich
or on the government for subsidies but
only the independent first it was the
independent landowner
we changed that idea and
evolutionary the middle class homeowner
the small business person but they were
economically and politically autonomous
and they were they took on the
responsibility time consuming to
participate in constitutional government
what's happened
until 2017 we'd have 13 years
of economic stagnation
we have right now 45 percent of the
americans die with less than 10 thousand
dollars in net worth
and most people 50 percent die with
money on their credit card that hasn't
been paid back
i think the most frightening is
we have 1.7
trillion dollars in aggregate debt right
now student debt and some kind of
nefarious bargain between the federal
government and these huge universities
that raise the cost of tuition and the
woman board faster than the rate of
inflation because there's no moral
hazard the federal government comes in
and subsidizes that loan and they don't
give a damn about what happens to the
student when they graduate
whether they're prepared to get a job or
whether they can service that debt
twenty percent of the debts are not
going to be paid back about 30 percent
are inactive
and it has repercussions on the middle
class
the age when people
marry has gone from 23 to 30.
the age of a first child is 25 to 22 32
and the age when people buy their first
home it's now
it we had made enormous strides uh at
the turn of the millennium we got up to
64
home ownership we're going backward now
and you can see this housing boom in
california nobody can buy a home that's
middle class
but
we're doing something that again i don't
want to quote all the philosophers but
tocqueville said one of the great
dangers
of a maternalistic democracy is
prolonged adolescence
these are people who do not want to go
out and face life
get married have children whether they
want to have children doesn't immaterial
buy a home be productive and you can see
it in the government during the
obamacare controversy do you remember
the pajama boy ad where we were all
supposed to listen to a man with
footsies and he was in his 20s and he
was in his pajamas drinking hot
chocolate and he said drink hot
chocolate be cool get obamacare i
thought who in the world would be
attracted and then i was told it was a
great success
the other ad was the life of julia do
you remember that ad
julia when she was born her mother had
fine noble thing federal prenatal care
when she was born she had one to three
federal assistants she went into a
federal and federal this and federal
doubt and it was bragging on the idea
that from the moment she was born to the
moment she died and i thought cradle to
grave was a pejorative but i saw today
that the new
reconciliation bill is called cradle to
grave benefits and the positive sin
there's nothing more injurious to
citizenship and a democracy than to have
a prolonged adolescent generation it
just doesn't work
the second challenge is you know in the
ancient world people love borders
the greeks would have something called a
horus a stone that marked out the limits
of thieves or corinth
or thespia or sparta
and sometimes they were natural
sometimes they were artificial but
borders were really important wars
started in the ancient world over
borders now why was that was it because
they were chauvinistic was it they were
militaristic no they felt that if you
did not have a special place
a landscape in which everybody shared
common values traditions
holidays rituals you could not inculcate
a cultural and social aspect that would
reinforce constitutional government we
have no border in the south now
we have
50 million people living in the united
states legally and otherwise that
we don't know their status but they were
not born in the united states some are
citizens some are legal residents but 20
million we know are illegal residents so
we are creating caste of citizenship
when you see a person 27 percent of the
california population was not born in
the united states so that one means when
i see somebody i don't know to what
degree we have a commonality other than
just residing there do they believe in
christmas do they
they know what iwo jima was do they have
any knowledge of gettysburg all the
civic rituals that are so important
so important to reinforce a
constitutional system it can't exist
just politics you have to reinforce it
constantly with shared experiences even
a shared physical space
and if you don't have that you have
nothing
and yet we have destroyed the idea
of
a border and why we're all guilty
central american governments in mexico
this year will get 60 billion dollars in
remittances from people illegally it's
the largest source of foreign exchange
and guess what most of that money will
be freed up because the federal local
and state government are subsidizing
people to allow them to have extra cash
to send back to countries that will
either cannot or will not help their own
people
it used to be common knowledge in mexico
it still is it's a safety valve rather
than marching on mexico city you'll go
to the united states so it really is
deleterious to the mexican people
because
a system is inherently racist and unfair
the dissident doesn't agitate they come
here it's almost like the reverse of
frederick jackson turner theory of the
frontier
only or we're the frontier
second thing is all of us and especially
in places
on the co the by coastal we have created
an aristocracy that depend on cheap
labor when i was going i don't remember
people in california of the upper middle
class having a gardener a nanny a cook
and yet they assume that that's a
birthright
and they're not worried about where what
the mechanics of that are are the
results on a society at large
and this is not just the left it's the
corporate right as well that wants cheap
labor and has driven down wages for the
middle class
and of course then there's the
democratic party they feel that these
constituents that you see on your screen
will have fealty to their party because
they will be generous in the
entitlements they feel that they'll
never be a california of ronald reagan
george took maize and pete wilson even
arnold schwarzenegger it's over with and
they have flipped nevada they feel they
flip new mexico they're about to flip
arizona they think they flip colorado
and it's a
pre-meditated idea of bringing people in
and so there was a lot of guilty parties
but you cannot have citizenship
when people are residents and we don't
know that there's any difference between
cast used to be that a citizen
was eligible for federal entitlements
they were allowed and only they were
allowed to go in and out of the country
because they had something after 1941
call a passport
and
they were
responsible for military service and
they alone could hold office or vote i
don't know how many of those still apply
i don't think any of them do
we have people i think it's a noble
thing that are in the military that are
not only not citizens but here illegally
we have people going back across the
border that don't need to have a
citizen's passport
if i come in or you come in from europe
and you don't have a passport you're not
going to get into the united states you
can come across the border and get in
the united states without a passport in
california and the local election board
in the bay area you don't have to be a
citizen to vote the la all i can see the
difference now
is that a citizen still can hold office
and somebody who's illegally here or a
mere resident that snotty says and
cannot i think that's just about ready
to go as well there's a third thing that
we were warned about about antiquity and
that's the danger of tribalism
when you read a historian like
thucydides they always start with the
idea that a pre-civilization pre-modern
society
has no meritocracy you hire your first
cousin or your general appearance
is essential not incidental to who you
are
and the tribe then is the enemy of
progress it's the enemy of meritocracy
i've been
i think to every country in the middle
east except iran when i talk to people
journalists there they always say
something it's it's a constant refrain
the reason that things don't work here
is because we hire our first cousin
and we don't hire the most capable
person because we judge people by their
blood ties or their superficial
appearance we had been fighting with a
legacy
of slavery and jim crow in the south
we've we're now in 50 years since the
civil rights movement and affirmative
action and we were starting to realize
martin luther king jr's dream of the
content of our character
rather than this color of our skin and
we've gone back 50 years with this woke
movement
we have this woke movement was not
started grassroots this is a top-down
phenomenon
this is
oprah winfrey from her 90 million dollar
statements montecito complaining about
ill treatment to meghan markle in her 15
million dollar
uh mansion this is brocco and michelle
obama worth 100 million dollars coming
out and then
pontificating on the unfairness as they
go back to their 38 acre 14 million
dollar martha vineyard estate i could go
on but you get the picture
the blm founder phyllis queller she's on
house number four in topaga canyon
professor kendy if you want to hear him
it's twenty thousand dollars three
hundred and thirty three dollars a
minute for his advice about how you must
be racist to stop racism and you must
discriminate to stop discrimination
and todd nahisi coates sort of the
godfather the guru of wokism
he's making a fortune
writing comic books and comic book
screenplays for hollywood these are not
revolutionaries out on the barricades
this is an elite driven
uh drive for the spoils of america
camouflage as if america is culpable
when i heard
general milley and the chief of naval
operations and the defense secretary say
that they were rooting out white
privilege white supremacy and white
whiteness
i did think
what's going on in afghanistan
why we were losing afghanistan while joe
biden was telling us everything was okay
in afghanistan they have 300 000 men
they have airport why he was calling the
afghan
president and stealthy saying even if
you're losing it please lie what was our
military doing
they were
cannibalizing their own ranks and when
general austin said we want every aspect
of our military to reflect
proportionality
okay
white males to take one example you
really want to go down that tribal road
where every single person
is is going to have a job based on their
racial component because that's a
trajectory to nihilism
and it's not even it's not even
represented we don't do that we did that
in the nba when we were racist and we
had it
the nba was not as exciting now we're
going 76 percent african-american i
think that's great it's based on merit
but it violates the very cannons of the
left that says you cannot do that
so when i heard mr when i heard austin
and miley say that i said okay
white males make up 33 of the population
they've died in in iraq at 75 percent
and they've died in afghanistan 74 are
you going to call up the afghan airport
and say hey anybody who's a white male
pull back you have you've died and over
represented so it's somebody else's turn
to go get killed so you can see where
we're going
the ultimate manifestation is a dna
badge
so we all try to adjudicate whether
we're going to go back to the south 1
16th drop
unless you think i'm kidding
elizabeth elizabeth warren tried that
didn't she and she found out she didn't
even have 1 16th jaw drop but she relied
on hyde's cheekbone she didn't have the
creativity and the imagination of ward
churchill who at least took the trouble
to dress up as a native american even
though he wasn't
and so that's what we're doing now
under the racism that was in the united
states especially in the south but it
was there
people then said i'm going to pass for
white it was a tragic experience because
they thought they would get
superior and discriminatory treatment
now it's i'm going to pass for non-white
so we come full circle but we're no
morally better than where we were and
this is tragic because we were on the
we were on the pathway to an assimilated
intermarried and integrated society
these are organic challenges of
citizenship but there's also
unfortunately a more deliberate planned
effort that's top down
from the elites what do i mean by elites
academics lawyers political activists
people where i work think tank
and
they also are eroding the idea of a
citizen one of the things that's really
scary i think you all agree is
what we now know is the administrative
state the deep state these are people
who are unelected
but they're deep in a bureaucracy
they're spiritual forefathers
or the 20 000 people at ancient athens
that were involved in some way with the
government of that democracy first
bureaucracy the word bureaucracy
remember comes from bureau in french the
death people the death bound that came
after
the revolution
byzantine it's a byzantine system the
huge
uh government class of thirty to forty
thousand at constantinople under
justinian the escorall the spanish
empire's class
people who really ran the french empire
and the old regime in france were not
the louis of various numbers they were
the bureaucrats at versailles
kings came and went and they stayed the
same that's what we have
and they are a judge jury and
executioner whether you're lois lerner
nobody elected her nobody gave should
have given her the power to tell which
particular
non-profit group gets to get non-profit
status depending on their political
views so if somebody
applies and they have the word liberty
and their application then they're
likely not to vote for barack obama they
do not get
they do not get non-profit status nobody
voted for anthony fauci and the cdc
where did we come up with the idea that
the cdc
could adjudicate whether you a landlord
can collect rent from somebody who's
living in your property and yet that's
that's what we're living under as i
speak
perhaps the locust classis was
the mueller investigation 40 million
dollars
22 months
the dream team the all-stars the killer
squad we were told these ivy league
lawyers and what did we end up with
we ended up with two
public servants both unelected robert
mueller going before
congress under oath when it was all said
and done
and they asked him
two questions
the font of this entire farce was
christopher steele's dossier remember
that all
he admitted in british court that he had
no sources
made it up and the second font was glenn
simpson and the fusion gps
that paid uh steel and then passed it
off to the government and mueller was
asked directly would you comment on the
christopher steele dossier and fusion
gps remember what he said i have no
knowledge of either one what are they
what are they you just spent 40 million
dollars using their evidence to go after
people in a political campaign to
destroy their civil liberties
the second thing that kind of epitomizes
it was james comey
unelected fbi leader
supposedly
sterling character he got under oath
under oath
in the congress house of representatives
he was asked
questions about the investigation his
leaking of memos his role with a forged
affidavit he said
245 times under oath i don't know or i
don't remember try that with the irs and
see what happens
and so i could go on but we are creating
unaccountable bureaucrats and
functionaries
that have combined the judicial the
executive and the legislative branch
into one person and they have enormous
resources out in california if you're a
farmer and you have a low spot
in your land and a federal epa official
decides that he doesn't like you or he
thinks that could have a high nitrogen
he can declare that an inland waterway
and reinterpret the epa act and find you
until you come out without your
permission and test your water
why
i can't think of a reason other than he
can
he can
and that's why he does it
there's a second group of people on the
elite that want to
denigrate or destroy or do away with
citizenship i'd call them the
evolutionaries
these are not just the permanent these
are people who feel that human nature is
malleable it changes
it's not fixed
and with greater resources nutrition
therapy
education you can make a new human and
if you have a new human you don't need
an old constitution
this was written by a bunch of old white
men who were
some of them were slave owners they were
in a different
era they weren't educated they didn't
have ipads and iphones they weren't
sophisticated and they wouldn't know how
to use google if they bought them back
here so we just need to junk that
and if it's not just the constitution
it's
150 180 years of tradition so no sooner
did this progressive movement take power
and they realized we do not have public
support
we came in through the covet crisis and
a lot of things that happened in that
terrible year 2020 so we've got to
change the system now we talked about
changing the demography but they said
first thing we've got to get rid of a
233 year old electoral college without
any discussion what it was for
if you read the constitution the
federalist papers it was to disperse
political power so that people would go
to rural areas because the founders had
a great distrust of what people are
capable
living in mass in crowded conditions and
they're prone to rumor and
spites of madness and frenzies and
somebody who was a cattle rancher or
farmer might be a check on them or they
thought if there was going to be fraud
you couldn't
accomplish it with a single national
election that would be broken up in the
states and they might check they get
various reasons they wanted immediately
to get rid of a
150-year tradition of a nine-person
court
would they have done that if donald
trump had not appointed three judges no
they want to pack the court pack the
court when we were all of us in college
was a dirty word that referred to
franklin roosevelt's 1937 scheme that
was roundly denounced by his own party
nobody mentioned it there is a website
packed the court and it's a term of
approbation celebration
there are a lot of arguments for a
hundred and eighty year filibuster the
only argument i can see that's being
induced to end it now is we're out of
power we want a ram we're in power we
want to ram this through and we don't
really care because nobody would be
crazy enough to give us power again so
we only have two more years
that is changing the system
we've had
we've had for for almost 70 years 50
states
it's not in the constitution but it's a
tradition it's a custom
why all of a sudden would we want to put
puerto rico
and d.c that's a federated
provincial idea
the idea that it wouldn't be partisan
were the capitalists why would we want
to make those states other than to give
them two representatives and four
senators and then be able to push
through legislation
in the near term it is in the
constitution that the primary
responsibility of voting is the is a
responsibility even a national election
of the states
and you know in michigan we vote
different than you do in california
different hours but the idea is unless
it's egregious
or unless the federal government feels
it's something of national concern like
women's suffrage or the 18 year old vote
the federal government keeps out not now
the first effort is to nationalize
voting
and why would that be
because for the first time in history 62
percent
of the electorate voted not on election
day
and the error rate for an absentee
ballot
and an early ballot traditionally had
been four to five percent
mysteriously it went down to 0.4 even as
more ballots were cast
that's a magnitude of 10. 102 million
ballots that could be
four or five million ballots if they
were placed in the right states
pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin
ohio they could
arizona
georgia they could affect the outcome
indeed mark zuckerberg believed that
because he put 500 million dollars to
enhance local precinct workers in these
states
and so now we're tampering with the
constitution
and trying to push through a national
voter's law
so this this is a very dangerous idea
that you're going to evolve the
government in our year of wisdom
suddenly in 2021 we
we discovered that we were geniuses and
the prior generations were idiots and
we're going to change the system because
it didn't work for us and now we have a
brief glimpse of power i want to finish
with a final challenge and that is
something that's also very old
uh the greeks call it called it
cosmopolitanism that meant i'm a
politician a citizen of the cosmos and
i'm not a citizen of athens or sparta
meaning we're global citizens globalism
did some good actually i mean it's a
good thing that people in the amazon
basin have penicillin
it's a good thing you can get eyeglasses
in mongolia it's really a euphemism
isn't it for westernization in the
economic sense consumerism
but the idea that globalization should
be extended to the political harmony of
the entire planet
really does mean that a very rare and
exceptional society that nobody's ever
seen before and will never see again the
united states is going to surrender its
sovereignty
globalization
enriched
boston to miami and people who had
professions that looked toward the eu
law academics media i know that suddenly
i was writing columns for 330 million
potential readers and it became six
billion
because of globalization
law firms entertainment hollywood
and in
california west coast from seattle all
the way to san diego but those
professions didn't necessarily represent
all of us people with muscular labor in
states like this or central valley of
california anything that could be
xeroxed and done more cheaply assembly
manufacturing small farming was done and
so when we confused cause and effect
and rather than saying the jobs left we
said the people got on meth or they were
worthless or they're uneducated and they
drove the jobs out we even created an
entire vocabulary of disparagement for
them do these words seem familiar on
national scene and candidates
clingers
deplorables
irredeemables
drags chumps
that's what barack obama and hillary
clinton and joe biden introduced to the
political vocabulary so we really in a
very strange way it was very un-american
we just divided the country and said
these guys
uh or as the cnn reporter said of a
rally these are the people
who have less teeth than i do
in aggregate or as peter stroke said to
lisa page have you gone to the smelly
walmart lately so we disparaged a whole
group of people we call them losers in
globalization
and then we we exaggerated the
brilliance of the people who had skills
that profited from globalization and out
of that is developing this idea that
we're really not americans we're
citizens of the world i'm not
exaggerating secretary of state
lincoln you remember what he just said
where he was calling in the u.n
commission on human rights to
investigate the degree of racism within
the united states
these are people like iran and north
korea i mean they're going to come in
and tell us that we're flawed the
international criminal court wants to
look whether into and they did the last
five years of the pres our presence in
afghanistan whether we were committing
particular crimes or not is if the u.s
military has lower standards than
countries like china
or again iran or countries in latin
america or asia and so de facto when you
surrender
sovereignty to a
fabian socialist in 1900 a league of
nations advocate
1920
somebody in the u and today you are
surrendering your freedom to something
that is let's face it it's an inferior
political concept it's only as strong as
its weakest link and the links are
pretty weak
and yet this is what
we're doing there's something going on
right now called the great reset
mr klaus schwab remember him he was the
off author and architect of davos the
idea is if you get bill gates and mark
zuckerberg and a lot of professors and
silicon valley wall street you bring
them all to davos
and they can plan out what the world
should be like and if you read his great
reset
he wants particular governments to
surrender sovereignty to an
international body the first thing he
wants to do is make sure that no one
country gives tax incentives to a
corporation like ireland does so that
corporations have nowhere to go except
to their body of high tax countries
redistributionists he wants corporate
boards to reflect diversity and their
membership should be appointed
on the color of their skin rather than
their ability to bring a profit to their
shareholders he wants to make sure that
we phase out
fossil fuels on a schedule that would be
turned by an international body and he
has enormous support within the united
states
one thing we should remember is the
democratic party is no longer the party
of the middle class if you look at the
top 20 zip codes in the united states
17 by income 17 voted democratic of the
20. if you look at congressional
districts by wealth the top 20 all voted
democratic
the republican party has
evolved into a upper and middle-class
party the democratic party is the very
very hyper-rich and the subsidized poor
we should we should remember that
because
a lot of what we've been talking about
are the efforts of very wealthy people
in wall street
silicon valley
professional sports
hollywood the corporate boardroom the
military to virtue signal their
superiority because they feel guilty
that they either don't feel comfortable
with a poor they don't want them around
and it's a very insidious
process this wokeness and this this
wealth
i don't mean wealth is good but the idea
that people have so much of it they're
exempt from the ramifications of their
own ideology
you want teachers union for others you
want prep schools for yourself
you want everybody to have solar panels
but you have a private jet
that type of attitude and that is what
globalism globalization has become let
me just finish and say let's not end on
a
sad note what can we the citizens do
and i think there's a lot of things we
can do the first things we can vote i
think there's going to be the greatest
reset if i could use klaus schwab's word
in the next midterm elections we've ever
seen
people are very angry
and it's not a white thing or a
conservative thing i live in a a city of
90 or mexican american middle class and
believe me they're very angry
and i think you're going to see a big
everybody has to vote
the second thing is i think people have
to according to their station everybody
has a different degree of autonomy and
freedom and protection and family
responsibilities
but they just have to say no
when they're called a racist
and so you can call me whatever one has
zero effect on me
if you're gonna cancel somebody out you
can say i could care less do your best
do your worst i'll do my best but we
have to all come out of the shadows and
with one voice say this is this wokeness
has a antecedent we know what wokeness
is
we saw it with the jacobins in the
french revolution we saw it with the
bolsheviks
that hijacked the russian revolution we
saw it with mao's cultural revolution
that killed 70 million people we know
where you're going and we're not going
to take this country
we have nothing apologize for the people
who fought at okinawa we have nothing to
apologize to the people who died at
gettysburg or the 600 000 that died to
freeze to end slavery this is a noble
tradition you're not going to hijack it
we also have to get confidence that
although we have lost
conservatives are worried about their
families their jobs their community
and they're not activists and then that
laxity of all of ours and i'm guilty
more guilty than anybody
the corporate board room was hijacked
the pentagon was hijacked
wall street was hijacked silicon valley
as i said sports entertainment hollywood
and they have enormous influence if you
go into google that search can be
adjudicated by a result that reflects a
political affinity
you donald trump cannot tweet on twitter
the taliban can
so they have enormous policy but they
don't have the people
all the polls show that every one of
these issues i talked about the american
people do not support it
and yet we have to find a voice and i
think the voices we have to go the on
the offensive and fight back and if
somebody calls you racist and they say
that they're going to do this and this
and this and this person
they're racist they're talking about
skin color there's nothing wrong with
saying the woke movement is racist to
the core it's elitist to the core it's
discriminatory to the core and i'm happy
to tell you that
every day of the week and if we do that
i think we can end it and again it's an
empowered citizenry that is the majority
you're not the minority and you're not
crazy thank you very much
so we have we have time for uh 10 15
minutes for some q a
as i suggested we've got mics over place
make yourself known to the person
holding the microphone and wait for it
and dr hansel will be happy to address
your question
i'm sorry i walked off i have such a big
mouth i talked i thought i went over my
time
i may have a mark as polite just a a
quick question what do you think of the
uh
the movement to remove all the statues
the
civil war statues and now they're
removing columbus and
well we have a a word for that it's
called
the greeks again
there was it's called iconicalism it's
what the taliban does i have no problem
if a municipality says
this particular statue is offensive in
this day and age and we're going to have
a committee
to study it and we're going to bring it
before the city council and we're going
to public discuss but that's not what
we're doing
they're all nocturnal
people go in the middle of the night and
tear things down without legal
authorization
and so that's my chief
complaint against it the other thing in
a broader sense is
it's
it's very
dubious
that we
the generation that is the wealthiest
and most affluent
in the history of civilization
look at history not as tragedy but
melodrama that we
are going to go back and we're going to
say that person is wanting according to
our standards
and therefore we're canceling them and
destroying them and we're going to take
that's what trusts that's
linen did that to trotsky stalin did
that the trotsky
so it's very dangerous to do the romans
call it damnatio memorial each
generation going back and attacking the
past
i think it would be very
difficult if i was in a covered wagon
and i was a woman who had to get
pregnant 15 times
to to have
10 births to come to term to have five
survive
childbirth and have three survive
childhood diseases when there were no
vacuum cleaners no cleansers and i was
on trying to get to
portland oregon in the willamette valley
and i'm all of a sudden to say i think
she was racist
i don't think she had anything in her
mind other how to survive one more day
and i think any of these antifa and blm
people that were in her place would be
dead in 10 seconds
so i have a great reverence for the path
and finally
remember people never think things are
going to boomerang we don't know what
people 50 years are going to say of us
but they may well say
wow what a primitive culture in 2020
reverted to pre-civilizational
racial tribalism and then aborts a
million people a year that they knew
they had the technology to save if they
were premature they may say that of us
and they would be
you know i can see why they would
we have a question to the speaker's left
yes dr hansen could you address the idea
and practice of birthright citizenship
either pre or post 14th amendment and
whether it has anything to do with the
dying citizen today
birthright citizenship is the idea that
the the vernaculars
anchor babies
and so in california and my hometown
uh people come across the border
pregnant and they have a child and that
anchors them later on and i'm not
exaggerating i've had people twice knock
on my door at night
and then spanish say do you know where
dr
x or y is in my little town i said how
do you know
they've heard of them
1500 miles away in oaxaca
that you come to these little towns it's
a good doctor he'll deliver your child
so there was it's
in the constitution in the 14th it's
debatable whether or not
people
who and i'm not going to get into
technicalities because i'm not qualified
in jurisprudence but whether
a person is subject to the laws of the
united states
when they're here illegally are subject
to the laws
of say mexico or honduras if they're
subject to the laws of their native born
state and they have not been
nationalized then if they have a child
then that child would not be a u.s
citizen
more practically
the more liberal countries in the world
the eu almost i think there's only three
of them that allow this
so everybody says the united states is
so conservative compared to europe
believe me in the last 10 years
we make a
conservative look like reagan we make
europe look like reagan country we
really do
economically even but especially on this
issue so it's very contentious and it's
been so
it's been it it's validity rest on court
interpretations of that in amendment and
i think that's going to be fluid
remember steve miller was hated because
that one of the first things he did is
trump's advisor said that he wanted to
revisit that with an executive war that
never happened
uh have you watched football lately
and do you have a comment about the
crowds of students and others that are
totally unmasked
well some crowds are more equal than
others yeah
i i
i've been chastised at where i work for
being quote out of my lane by commenting
on
medical issues because i'm not qualified
although i'm a very close friend one of
my best colleagues at the who is scott
atlas and i do think that there's an
argument that the swedish model
that was to keep the economy and and to
hoard your resources or to direct them
toward vulnerable people rather than
trying to cover everybody with masks and
lockdowns might in the end
be more advantageous i got vaccinated as
soon as i was eligible but
so that's an issue but what your point
is i think is well taken i didn't
understand that we were told follow the
science
and then in june of 2020 we had 5 000
people in a blm rally with no mask as
well as an la laker victory lowry and
then we were told by the scientists
remember 1100 medical providers signed a
petition
that said it would be more injurious to
the mental health of the protesters to
forbid them
from breaking the law by
massing uh
in street demonstration at that point i
said there is no wall it's total chaos
and people make it up as they go
and as we've seen it's
in times of panic in times of mass
hysteria in times of perceived
danger
our constitutional liberties are the
first to go
and i i i think covet is a very
dangerous disease because while 99
percent of us are not going to die with
it
not i've seen people who are healthy
that for some immunological reason die
from it so it's something that may may
be different from the flu but not
different enough to sacrifice the first
second third fourth fifth sixth seven
eight ninth amendments and that's what
we've done
we have a question to the speakers left
hello sir thank you so much for that
answer and i think we should all have a
peaceful mostly peaceful protests
against ohio state football
i i would like to ask more seriously in
terms of it seems like the citizen is a
creation of western civilization and it
seems like western civilization is the
one leading the wokeness of our recent
times what is eastern civilization most
notably china uh doing in regards to the
wokeness or are they just waiting us for
through implode from it and have every
the world fall into their laps
did everybody hear that
yeah well
remember this is not the soviet union
china
this is 1.5 billion people and they have
a very
uh eerie machiavelli infusion of
elements of free market capitalism with
state control under the veneer of
communism that is far more productive at
least so far than the soviet union ever
was and they have a degree
of sophisticated propaganda that makes
the old apparat from the soviet union
look like rookies
i teach at a university where somebody
just calmly announced oh by the way that
visiting professor of neuroscience we
found out she was working for the
chinese communist military
okay
and we have 380
000 students
in the united states that are chinese
many of them the vast majority are here
to study but if it was only one percent
that's more people working for the
chinese communist party
as their students and remember a high
proportion of the students here are
connected with
provincial government and high-ranking
government officials in china that's one
of the ironies about it so they
understand the united states better than
anybody better than we do
so when this woke thing started
i said to my wife
once we found out
that it came from wuhan and once the
chinese government as soon as the
chinese government said it
it was a bat or a pangolin had nothing
to do with the stage four biology lab
that had a hand with the military i
thought that's it ev you did too
everybody knew that and it was
engineered but as soon as that
i said to
jennifer watch what follows next and it
wasn't more than a week later then we
were racist
now you can call ebola the ebola virus
for ebola you can call valley fever
because it's from the san joaquin valley
you can call lyme disease because
someone you say wuhan virus or then
you're a racist and that's what these
and this is a time when they put a
million and a half people
in the wager concentration camps and
they were pulling african
uh residents off the streets of beijing
to check whether only they were infected
it's the most racist country in the
world today and yet they understood the
woke mind
and remember one thing about
the chinese propaganda effort
we think in our arrogance
that our magnaminity and our superior
morality will be interpreted by them
as
welcome and will be reciprocated in kind
they look at it as weakness to be
exploited
and they think if i had all that power
and i had an economy 40 bigger than us
and they do it with 330 million not 1.5
and one american worker even in this
midnight hour of america still produces
far more goods and services than his
four counterparts in china if i had an
800 billion dollar budget if i had 7 000
nukes if i had 18 of the top 20 research
institutions in the world if i had all
that gas and oil
i would be doing things that would make
what we're doing now the silk road the
belt looked like nothing we would
actually have our world hegemony so they
look at our constitutional system
and our sense of restraint as weakness
it doesn't mean we shouldn't do this
but we shouldn't take them seriously
when china says that we're racist we
should say thank you coming from a
racist country that means you're racist
but we don't do that because it's part
of the woke movement china has said
china has said
they're the big propagandists behind
this myth that there's a bunch of white
nuts
from dayton ohio that are driving all
the way to
the bronx and manhattan and oakland and
beating up asian americans
we know that whether it's fair not we
know that about 75 percent
of the recorded attacks on asian
americans are coming from
african-american
youth between 15 and 50. yet china would
have us believe that this racist country
that uses the word china virus is now
attacking its own citizens and they've
got half the country believing
they know more about propaganda and how
the americans are so sensitive to the
charge of being racist or discriminatory
than we do ourselves so i think we
should be
very careful that we have never had a
rival like china that is so
sophisticated not just
in its advantages in population economy
military we could go through i'll talk
all night about that but so
sophisticated in its understanding
of 21st century american pathologies and
how to exploit them and do it in a way
that the american left
celebrates it's a very dangerous time
thank you
[Applause]
thank you to what extent do you think
the elites that you spoke of are
empowered by their ability to
without any restraint print fiat
and do you believe that
what's happening say in el salvador only
by way of example where bitcoin has
become legal tender
will allow the world to have a central
bank without central bankers
i'm not qualified even though i should
because i live in silicon i mean i work
in silicon valley about bitcoins
cryptocurrencies but i think all of us
are confused that
george bush over eight years almost
doubled the national debt barack obama
and eight years double the national debt
donald trump was on a trajectory in
eight years to double but we have not
seen anything like
what joe biden is doing we were coming
out of a recession
we were having pinup demand of a year
and a half
there was a natural exuberance that
people wanted to go out and travel they
wanted to eat so we had a natural
stimulation what we did not want to do
is two things
discourage productivity and pay more
money for people to stay home than to be
active
and
exhaust our
stimulatory powers by printing more
money and then jawboing job-boning
producers by threatening them with
capital gains estate taxes income tax
hikes on the rise more regulation so he
did everything opposite and he's
printing this money he wants 3.5
trillion dollars to be printed at a top
quantitative easing whatever the proper
term at a time we're almost at 30
trillion dollars so
when you look at
economic theorists and people in the
universities on the left
they're not saying anymore as they used
to say well the republicans did it too
or this is temporary or we're going to
tax you and pay you back they're
starting to say
there is really no such thing as debt
and money is a construct
and printing it is okay and they and
they don't believe in classical
economics of debt
and obligation and contractual
obligations so that that's what's scary
that
this radical spending or even the
suspension of
rent to a landlord
or the idea that you pay somebody to
stay home we're in a revolutionary
period of economics where we have p p
people and these are not
people from selma california where i
live these are people at stanford and
harvard and yale and the federal reserve
they really do believe that they have
discovered a new
horizon a new frontier in economics that
will allow them to just create this
artificial debt and there's no
historical
support for it and whether it's a
marxist idea that it destroys the
capital of people who have money by
printing more money than population
gains or productivity i don't know
but for the first time in my life i'm
reading from
quote-unquote reputable
economics uh professors that we don't
have to pay that back or barack obama
i'll finish with this said when he was
asked about
the reconciliation stimulatory package
and then the infrastructure he said i
really don't think this is the time that
we really have to worry about paying the
money back
think of that because the united states
i don't want to end on a sad note but i
guess i did thank you
thank you everyone
we're under strict orders to end by nine
o'clock and so the speaking portion is
over but there is hospitality outside
and the books available as well thank
you for being here
you